hey phil start a game okay this is
awesome
sweet so um this will be my student for
probably the next hour or so after
after the game finishes we'll hop on
call
and phil is playing white i do have the
fill command
which kind of explains who he is pretty
well known figure
in the poker community and he'll be
participating in this uh
chest tournament for poker players so
over the course of the next like month
or two i'll probably get be giving more
on-stream lessons to participants of
this tournament
um and yeah he actually already had a
lesson with anna rudolph a couple days
ago
and i know he's a big fan of the job of
london which he's kind of
playing here even though this came from
an england gambit
um
interesting play
nothing wrong so far it's a it's a bit
more exotic than
than what most people do with the the
king side advance
but one uh one strategy i think
phil probably knows this but when you
advance the pawns
on the king side very often you end up
casting queen side
i like queen d4 queen g4 is a really
nice move because white's preparing to
castle queenside but also
making it so if black castle's queen
inside the a7 pawn
falls
it's hard to remove the queen
yeah this is a really nice setup
actually
because black can't really castle this
way if black castles this way white's in
really good shape to attack
like h4h5
yeah this is this is phil's wheelhouse
he's uh i know he uh he studied the
simon williams course like really in
depth
um so the play so far
is probably at a much higher level and
black hasn't really gone wrong
either just a
slightly less pleasant position for
black
and we might cover a little bit of this
in the lesson
but uh like transitioning from the
opening to the middle game
because he he got his kind of nice setup
but then the question is what to do next
and especially in position oh he grabs a
pawn
i was gonna say especially in positions
with opposites like castling
usually you want to attack as quickly as
possible
um i think that was actually a blunder
because
black had rooked e8
but black instead went for just
basically the trade of pawns
getting messy these pawns are hanging
this pawn's hanging
i still like white's position if we go
back a few moves um
if black played rook to eat here this
could have been
very troublesome for white
like white should have probably should
have stormed on the king side in some
way
yeah this is it's probably what i would
play
defending the pawn the downside of this
move is the c file becomes half open
[Music]
um okay pawns are falling left
left and right and maybe center but
actually now
so the fact that white lost after the g
pawn now the the files are half open
so the rooks could come in potentially
but you probably don't want to allow
queen jake's e3 forcing the queen trade
oh also this is a threat
actually a scary position
also hello to those just joining um
yeah this is basically the first part of
the lesson
even though we're not on call yet i like
king b1
this is a move that phil should be very
um
very familiar with playing especially in
these sort of openings like king is just
safer there
h5 nice move
um very open position it's very easy to
go wrong for either side here
h6 playing like alpha zero
but just losing a pawn but now okay all
the files are open
so the rooks can uh can have some fun
he's probably thinking about stacking
lesson with anna the other day they were
talking about sacking
sack material for the attack oh
i don't think that's what i would have
played it's interesting though
white gets initiative
it's actually a really cool game
if he wins this game then he can be
compared to like tall or morphy
if he loses then
uh he can be compared to like pogchamps
participants
but there's some lasting pressure here
the knight is pinned
the problem yeah the problem is black's
pieces are good
ooh i honestly did not see that move
i think more like stay on the king side
but
i mean that looks like a free pawn
now the question is will he see the fact
that the queen is defending
from far away
and will he not will he make sure he
doesn't get made on the back rank
so there are some landmines for white
that's playable
is there increment oh there might not be
increment here
all right let's watch oh there's
increment i think
i'm not seeing the time control a3 was a
good move i was just gonna say that
um it's so important to make like a just
a safe square
for the king what we call making luft
so now black is trying to attack
now white wins the pawn it's actually a
crazy position i don't know how valuable
the extra rook is
it's not a decisive advantage for black
at all
both kings kind of unsafe
i really got to watch the time
i'm trying to figure out the exact
increment
because it just says five minutes but i
saw the time go up after a move was made
also maybe queen here
these open positions it's so important
to like see the whole board
oh no your time you gotta move where's
the recaro extension
recaro save oh no it's too late
oh no okay well
oh that was a really cool game though
that's like something we can start with
oh queen e7 also playable
yeah a couple ways to fork the the
knight in the rook
yeah just move i have to learn how to
say it like a really mean
and urgent way hello hey
phil how's it going oh i'm so bad
ah well that was super fun to watch uh
i got in time trouble i panicked
i know of i was running early
and have me every time nice to speak
with you i'm a little tilted right now
but um thank you so much for having me
on oh yeah it's a pleasure i mean it
tilt is a natural feeling after a game
like that you were
you were close to pulling off the
brilliancy i i was saying that if you
won the game you'd be compared to morphy
because it was the same style as this
whole attacking team
attacking uh on the king side but
there's a lot of lessons to take away
yeah uh play longer games
yeah playing longer games i've been at
games i'm just not
i'm not strong enough to see what i'm
supposed to do in time i felt like i
i had a winning thing i had a winning
position like
half you know right out of like move 15
or move
17 or something and then i just fell
apart i don't know
yeah and we can if you want to start by
by just going through
uh maybe just a few of the key moments
because there were definitely some
missed opportunities where uh
yeah you you had chances to really just
tear apart your opponent
yeah i would love that i would love the
uh sensei's
uh instruction on on how to make it
better i think i
i think one of the things that i forgot
to do i've got to move the
the rook the d-rook over to the g-file
yeah so i was watching your lesson with
anna another day
and you guys covered a lot of similar
concepts
which you could have applied in this
game in terms of like building up the
attack
before you go absolutely insane and just
sack everything hoping it works
[Laughter]
so sometimes it takes a few times
to put the study into practice yeah for
sure
um so i'll i'll go ahead and
send you an invite let me see if i can
actually load this up
all right okay so and now you see the
pieces moving i hope
yes okay yeah so you uh
it seemed like you just kind of stuck
with your comfort zone of playing like
this joe bava
london setup even though it was more of
a
this is what we call the england gambits
when black plays
yeah i don't like it when they do this
against me i'm much more comfortable if
they don't
i know a lot more of the lines when they
don't push that e pawn so early sure
yeah this kind of disturbs your whole
setup because you can't play the media
bishop f4
and do your normal stuff at the same
time this is
just kind of a dubious move and yeah
like just taking it is the best approach
and
like what you did in the game was
actually really nice just like
developing
very naturally um
[Music]
and i don't really have too much
criticism
uh actually i like what you did because
you you expanded on the king side you
got very playable middle game position
i was praising this move queen d4 as
just like a really nice
uh not only improving move but you
prevent black from casting queen side
because then yeah that's what that was
my main goal i was like well why
why he's trying to go queen side and i'm
like well i'm gonna
forget that and then i'm not gonna let
him ruin my pawn structure i'll protect
my bishop at the same time
definitely yeah and you created a
situation where like box king was a
little bit
stuck because you casted queenside
and then if black castles kingside which
is what happened the game
you were in full kind of full attacking
mode i was ready to go
and that that's why yeah when i get this
queen side castle and they go king i
know i'm ready to
to go but i think i i forgot to move the
rook to the g file before i got going
a bit later yeah maybe there is some
improvements uh of course first you had
to deal with your queen you you move
back this is fine
and then so here there was a tactical
moment
i think both of you you and your
opponent missed
uh this possibility um you took the
packages
upon right now yeah yeah which which you
did
upon right but the problem is
you you put this bishop in danger and
black has a really powerful response
to basically punish the fact that your
bishop is aligned with your queen
just moves then that moves the rocco so
rook d8 and all of a sudden like your
bishop's pin you're probably going to be
losing a pc
yeah so this pawn on d6 even though it
looked
free it was just what we call a poison
pawn
not worth taking yeah uh you were much
better off
uh probably just focusing on the king's
side making some
uh some clear attacking move i mean you
could start with h5
i mean these moves always you can
consider if you notice the fact that
queen's attacking your
f pawn maybe a simple move here is e4
justin
[Music]
um your knight still supports the bishop
and then
when you play e4 you're you're securing
control over d5 as well which is nice
for your knight eventually
um but let's let's get to the juicy part
of the game because
a lot of things got traded king b1 was a
really nice move
very often when you castle queenside
your king's just safer
um like towards edge rather than towards
the center
well i knew i was gonna lose the e3 pawn
and
i didn't want to get in check at the
same time yeah that's very true
actually the the reason to play king b1
is that when
the queen takes on e3 you're not forced
to trade queens
you can just drive your queen to a
square
like even f5 because you're you're in
better shape still to attack on the
king's side
um and then coming up here this reminded
me exactly of that that moment
in your lesson with anna which i i
watched the whole thing last night it
was a great lesson by the way
um where like the the decision is
whether to sack immediately
or to play like some kind of preparatory
move
yeah and sagging almost worked out but
uh but rook g1 it's just a lower risk
move that you can play
pretty quickly
yeah and then you're threatening to take
on h6 and black is still
under a lot of pressure and actually the
fact that you've lost
like all of your your king side pawns
like fg and h-pawn
in some sense it benefits you because
you have the files for your rooks
yep um there's a quote that i like to
say every pawn lost is a file opened
so sometimes you're okay with losing
pawns just so your rooks become happier
um but then okay what happened the game
there's one more moment just
just a tactical moment i want to point
out here
maybe even have you find the the move
here because
at this point you were you were very low
on time and
um yeah i think uh you just
ended up losing on time but in this
position
uh i want you to look for tactics it's
white
oh i can go uh seven and
and fork yep yeah queens are so good
like in open positions especially when
there's undefended pieces
to kind of use the board geometry um
queen e7 i think guarantees you to win i
might
be wondering if i can move in yeah i'm
pretty sure white is winning here
um checking yeah engine is giving like
plus
four almost that's barely winning
yeah still anything could happen like in
time pressure but
um i i think a game like this is like
kind of good preparation
for your tournament situation or your
upcoming tournament because you're gonna
you're gonna be in situations where
you're pressured on time or you have to
rely on instinct
you really have to manage your time and
sometimes make
make quick decisions so yeah
another tactic here is queen b6
which i i thought i saw initially this
isn't as good though
even though you attacked the rook and
the knight
uh let me ask you what can black do to
defend here
uh what could
black do to defend um
um
what kenny um
i'll give you kind of just general
advice
when two pieces are attacked sometimes
what you can do is use one of the pieces
to defend the other pieces and the other
okay yeah rook to e-8
rookie yeah actually this uh
this would defend the night the pawn
would still fall but
this is of course better for black
compared to the other line with queen e7
um anyway that was that was a nice warm
up um
and i i think i think your white
repertoire
as you as we kind of chatted about uh
i guess before this lesson and i i know
you mentioned with your
in your lesson with anna that your your
white repertoire is a lot more
um kind of comfortable
and maybe your black rapitar is uh the
thing that needs work
yeah well i um so i've studied it a lot
right it's always easier to play and i'm
gonna i like to attack so it's easier to
to get into an attacking situation with
white um
but i've also i bought the simon
williams uh java london course on
chesable and that guy's just a he's got
such a great
style on video did an amazing job with
that
with that i think um highly recommend it
i think it shows in your play too like
seeing your games if it seems like you
understand the joe pava london
even better than a lot of like expert
level players oh 15 hours three times
and like
work through all the chessable click
click click click that's impressive
um but yeah uh i i understand a little
bit more about that one
um you know i'm a new chess player i've
only been playing for
less than a year um
and uh yeah but i i really like that
course
um i don't know it i i don't get
lost i you know like completely just
blown off the board and and and that um
and that opening for white very often um
you know give my opponents a chance to
mess up every once in a while
definitely and i think that's kind of
what you what you're looking for in an
opening
so like you you have some sense what to
do early on
um you're getting kind of the same um
not only like
the same kind of opening setup but also
leading into the middle game
you'll get a lot of recurring middle
game ideas a lot of situations where you
end up casting queen side
attacking on the king's side yeah and
that yeah i love that i love that setup
i i don't know it just suits my it suits
me better to
castle queen side and go all in on the
king side
definitely yeah that makes a ton of
sense um and
i think probably what we should focus on
is
improving your black openings and i know
we talked a little bit about this
working on something that you're you're
a bit more comfortable with where you
don't like lose immediately
yeah i i get a lot of uh
a lot of black games that are over in
seven moves you know where i just
have no earthly idea what to do yeah and
i
i went ahead and looked at some of your
recent
blitz games and i saw some pretty
pretty clear disasters yeah um
do you even i i i have some of them
saved i could bring them in if you want
to oh no
yeah unless uh or we could focus on
something uh
let's let's learn um let's go let's move
forward not looking for the past
sounds good okay so i i know you were
playing this like e6 b6
which is something you can kind of save
as kind of a another weapon
but um i know we should probably expand
course on that um but evidently
it hasn't sunk in um because i still
lose way too
quickly i don't mind losing i just don't
want to lose quickly
i think you know at the 1213 you know
i've i've been as high as 1377.
i don't know what's wrong with me now um
but um at this level just giving your
opponent rope just sticking around long
enough where you're not clearly just
you know blundered a piece or whatever
give them enough time to blunder
you know that that seems to be a good
thing um
i need something that'll keep me around
in the game a little bit longer so that
i've got a chance definitely and that's
really what the strategy should be just
got out of the opening alive
with with a position where you have some
sense like where your pieces should go
where you're not like losing immediately
and then like most of the games um
really at any level are not determined
in the opening
but determined later on in the middle
game usually by tactics or blunders
or by like the eventual time scramble or
end games
so um that's where like more of the
focus should be
but getting you off on the right footing
where you're you're not losing in the
opening is maybe the first step
and uh hopefully we can we can give you
just a more solid rapper tour
um and i know you
you made an effort to learn the french
at some point
oh i bought i spent two hundred dollars
on an excuse
repertoire and
uh i think i lasted seven minutes um
it's nothing i mean he's an amazing
player i love watching him but
i could not follow along at the speed at
which he was
trying to teach um that was the wrong
choice for me
yeah a slightly expensive mistake maybe
but
yeah i i think yeah that's of course
my contribution to is uh his greatness
um
i'm not asking for a refund maybe maybe
in two or three years i might be on a
spot
a better spot yeah who knows like maybe
maybe in a few years you'll you'll be
like
uh you'll be a much stronger player and
the the course will actually make sense
yeah and i don't think there's a resale
market for it right now otherwise i'd be
offering it half price yeah
maybe you can search the the dark web
for i don't know
but probably not the best use of your
time
um so yeah um i know we we chat a little
bit
uh just with anna about what openings
you sh
what would make sense to pursue because
the french i think is still like a very
friendly kind of stable opening where if
you know
some of the basic ideas you you can get
like a
pretty easy position to play and um
and be more comfortable than your
opponent um but then the other thing
like when you're black
you not only have to be prepared for e4
you have to be prepared for d4
um right so we can like we we can focus
on e4 and look at french we can focus on
d4 and look at like queens gambit in
london
um we do want to cover everything
eventually but i think for today
we should start with uh with maybe e4 or
d4
um let's go let's go french i'm a little
bit
a little bit more familiar with those
okay and
do you know how to flip the board um you
have the little toggle thing
yeah so you should look from black's
perspective yeah yep
and with french
there are different things white can
play but maybe we'll play out the game
we'll see where it goes and
i'll test kind of the the knowledge that
you acquired from this geary course
and we'll see how far that takes you
okay so i'm gonna i'll start with this
um was one of the most common variations
okay i go like i go like that
okay and i go like that putting more
pressure on the d-pawn
and now i've got a few options i usually
sometimes
i think you're supposed to go like that
although that doesn't
get pretty complicated i think there
there are a few options i would
recommend
queen b6 okay and i mean
the thing with french like there there
is a lot of like specific
lines like if you want to learn it at a
high level there is approach of trying
to
like memorize all the specific lines but
then there's approach of just kind of
understanding where your pieces should
go understanding
kind of your ideal setup and i think
that's probably a easier approach
to begin with because not all your
opponents
will go into specific like theory and
uh you should just understand kind of
the basic plans and concepts
um but so common especially when you get
kind of this typical french structure
where white advances
the pawn early one of your main ideas
is to build up a lot of pressure against
d4
with your pawn knight and queen so queen
v6 is a move that you don't really have
to think too much about it's just
usually where your queen should go
in the french and there's a few ways
white can try and deal with this
we'll start with some of the potential
mistakes white can make
let's imagine bishop to e3
what comes to mind here okay
uh okay
so um i can't really take you got too
many defenders now
um so obviously i assume you're counting
like defenders and attackers white has
four defenders on on g4
yeah so i
really it feels like i want to get
castled if i can um i i got a long way
to go to get castle day
uh i've seen the
h6 thing in in a couple of videos where
okay i can take it but not a big deal
i'll take back to the pawn and i get the
open g file and he's not castled yet
either
um but if he doesn't then i'm going to
put the
i'm going to put the knight on f5 um
in the next move and put another put
another attacker there
it's funny i was playing blitz earlier
uh i don't know if you were watching
like one of my earlier blitz games but i
had the same sort of idea
from a french structure um yeah
this is a good one to know um
we're gonna come back to this because
i want to tell you right away this this
move was a terrible mistake from lights
and oh i see yeah i can just uh hose you
right there
i don't think you made a move but i
assume you're seeing queen takes b2
yeah yeah queen b2 is it's just a free
pawn
um and the bishop
usually when your queen comes to b6 the
bishop is just tied down to c1
so right it's one benefit when you play
the french when you get your queen here
you not only pressure the d4 pawn but
you tie down the bishop on c1
yeah and whenever
like even in the opening but this
applies to any stage of the game
whenever your opponent makes a move you
want to be aware of what changes
in the position what potential squares
or pawns are left undefended
um so
white white does have to be a bit more
careful here
um let's look at another move let's say
bishop d3
how would you react to this move
so my
so now i've got and now if i take you
take
yeah i've got now i've got three
attackers and you only have two
defenders because the bishop's in the
way
i think i can tell that's good okay so
you can count um
that's yeah as a poker player that's a
very important skill
um math is coming in handy yeah
so this is great that we're covering uh
this now and that you're not kind of
gonna suffer in the future when you get
this in a game because if if this
happened in the game
black is is completely lost here and i
want you to look at one more move ahead
because you you felt for actually one of
the most common traps that french
players fall for
what oh you're gonna go like that
there's a b5 and the yeah
the queen uh the queen is lost um
so even though
you were right like you had three
attackers we can say d4
is still defended by irish tactics
yeah so yeah
so you have a move here you have a move
here
to basically deal with the fact that
white
hat white's going to be threatening
bishop b5 in the end
um oh i'm supposed to go like that
i'm supposed to go i'm supposed to put
the bishop in front of the king
bishop d7 yeah um that way i remember
now
yeah now now if white does something
out they don't now like thing and
yeah now i can go then you can take and
after it takes takes
so whenever you want to basically take
on d4 you have to make sure that there's
no
potential check the bishop can give
right i remember now
um and then yeah then you'd win like a
key center pawn
against a lot of like weaker players
sometimes you can get away with winning
the pawn early in the center
um now this is this is actually a gambit
uh this this is a a potential gambit
white can play
where like gives away the pawn tries to
get
some like early initiative because your
queen's kind of a target
this is not something you have to worry
too much about i don't think you'll
encounter this too often at
your level and very often you can just
complete developing
like 97 bring the knight to c6 bring the
bishop in castle
and then this pawn is also going to be a
potential weakness later so
i would uh what do you think about the
enchanto here
because it feels like if i go if i go
with the knight
there it's like four moves to get
everything settled but if i go
uh it goes here i can put
right and now i can it's a little bit
faster i
it feels like i'm maybe i'm wrong but
it's one possibility um
it's actually
it's not so much faster and one thing
actually i'll i'll probably give you
kind of a hard rule
that in most cases you don't want to fee
in shadow
or fiance in the french just because
when you commit to e6
and g6 it's weakening to f6
and very often you just want to leave
the pawn back
okay if you
if you want to try and be a bit safer on
the king side like most often the bishop
will come here
or here
on just kind of a better uh better more
central
square um another approach to kind of
keep the king's side safe is to bring
the knight t7 and then g6
where you then kind of block the
diagonal and you still pressure the pawn
on e5
okay yeah that looks that looks good
my my first instinct
here would be uh put the bishop behind
the queen make the battery or whatever
you're supposed to call it
um that to me
that feels like a fill move uh like
bishops i don't know
i don't know i don't know if it's the
best move but bishop c5 it feels like
something that i would do if it's not
terrible
sure yeah and that's also possible um
actually bishop c5
there's a lot of playable moves here um
and this is like this is a position
that's been studied
for probably at least like a hundred
years there's probably books from about
this uh
specific opening um
but like if you can just kind of develop
castle and not plunder anything
that's usually the primary plan when you
play bishop c5
sometimes the the main thing you want to
be concerned about is
bishop e3 where then you're you're
skewered
um but this isn't the like a big issue
for you because you do have a square for
your queen
to then still keep the bishop defended
yeah it's queen b4 yeah and even if your
queen gets kicked you can move back
to b6 and you keep everything under
control
and you're still up a pawn and you're
gonna complete development and
um yeah you're doing fine here
so so yeah that's just one example line
of when you win the pawn early
and uh and white didn't really
not too early
yeah so very important to recognize uh
the potential right
um so when you play bishop d7 here
um perhaps more often white will try and
actually keep the pawn defended
uh and there are a few moves here for
white maybe the most kind of natural
looking is bishop to c2
um then just kind of unleashing the
queen so now there there are three
defenders
yeah well now i know i
just i'm not he's not really threatening
anything i don't
think i just i just
i want to get castled
but it i don't really like this deep if
i move my knight
first then my d-pawn
i don't really want to have to take back
with the queen
i don't know um maybe it's better to
trade him now
yeah so trading now is actually a very
fair
approach and you make a good point if
you move the knight now
uh to e7 then
then white could take and your queen
gets a little bit iffy
um so after bishop c2
taking on on d4 is timely and very often
when you take on d4
white takes back then you have an
additional square to work with
now now that the c pawn is no longer
here
it is this b4 square i can go
check and we'll move as something and
yep and bishop b4 check uh completely
fine developing move knight c3
and 97 and you're getting castled um now
there there are a few things to address
because you have to be careful of like
dealing with uh with potential king side
attacks
um and we might go back one thing that
happened to me
it happens to me a lot um
i see both those bishops bearing down on
the king side as queen
can get over there quick as knights one
more move he's got the e5 pawn which is
like
one of those pawns that that i've heard
sets up the greek gift or
is that what it's called so there is of
like exactly the greek gift which could
happen if you're not careful
yeah and it just looks terrible to
castle that side but i've already
screwed my clean side i don't want to go
that way either
so i i want to show you like what could
go very wrong
and then then i'm going to show you
actually we're going to go probably a
few moves back and show
even better way for you to to be extra
safe and
together um a clearly better position
um okay but first i want to show just a
clear example of
a greek gift like let's imagine like
develops
and then like you're so you were so
focused on casting getting your king
safe
but now uh your king is
basically everything but safe after the
greek gift starting with bishop h7
yeah yeah this is a very very
common tactical sequence especially from
the french
the french is probably like the one
opening where this
this sequence happens the most
yeah regardless of whether you playing
yeah like king takes h7 knight g5 just
to show that the full sequence here
if you move back trying to save yourself
then queen h5 happens
you uh i mean you're practically getting
mated
almost by force you can move your rook
let's say like
rook e8 um but your whole king side is
crumbling there's queen takes f7
and then the queen moves back and you're
getting checked all over the place
um there might not be an easy win
for white but a move like queen h5 here
threatening this is
uh it's not something you want to deal
with
and um yeah no it's better to learn this
lesson
in analysis in like a teaching session
like this rather than
like a serious competitive especially
tournament game
um yeah i feel like people learn that
learn this uh oh my god i can sack that
bishop pretty early
yeah um and the guys i'm gonna be
competing against
and nothing would make them happier than
than pulling that
destroying you with a greek gift yeah
especially in front of tens of thousands
of people
yeah um so we're not gonna let that
happen
so um if you do like whenever you castle
you should ask yourself if
if your king's side is vulnerable
because sometimes it's just a matter of
playing a move like h6
and there's cases where your king just
stays in the center and it's it's even
more safe in the center
because it's hard for white to to get to
there's cases also where you're the one
attacking on the king's side with h6g5
um especially if light castles and then
you can maybe use this plan
um i want to go back actually a few
moves because
there was an even better way of playing
which was a little bit counter-intuitive
but hopefully when i show it it will
make sense
and it's an idea to to really keep in
mind
as a french player it's in this position
and the move that you were most inclined
to play was was bishop e4 check like
just completing development
even like gaining a tempo because you
develop with check
um but there's kind of a positional
rule in the french where
one of white's best pieces in this
structure is a light squared bishop
it's like white's most dangerous piece
because it's the one that's usually used
to create this
uh these attacking ideas on the king
side
so sometimes you want to go out of your
way to trade off
this bishop so then you don't even have
to live in fear
later in the middle game yeah
um so do you see a move here which
aims to trade off or just aims to get
rid of the
the bishop on c2
i could go knight uh c or knight to b4
knight b4
yeah and even though you're violating
some
kind of opening principle like you are
moving away from the center you're
moving the same piece twice
you can get away with it in this
position because you're you're still
like rock solid like you're
not vulnerable in any way here and if if
you can make this trade then it's
it just makes life a lot easier for you
and your king's side will be less in
danger later on
um if we look for mike's perspective
it's hard to actually
save the bishop effectively white could
play bishop b3 but then the bishop's on
a terrible square like it's just staring
at the face of your pawn chain
and not only this but after bishop here
then you can you have a nice way to
really
potentially destroy white right away
with bishop to b5
yeah i was looking at that to keep him
from castling not only preventing light
from casting which is
already really nice but then you're
threatening knight d3 here
and it's just a weak square in white's
territory you're controlling more times
if you get the knight to d3 it can be
very very troublesome for white
imagine white just kind of ignores
everything develops
knight d3 and then white white has
nowhere good to go with a king
king here here aligns with your bishop
right and then you have a discovery you
take on b2 hitting the
king and the queen and then if king d2
you take on f2 with a fork
so game over yeah it goes to show like
how quickly white's position can crumble
with just
a couple wrong moves ooh i like that
um yeah and this really started from
uh after bishop d7 bishop c2
this is a moment where like you should
already have the intention of taking
with the idea of getting the knight here
to trade off the bishop
okay and it's hard for lightning so
that's something to do with that
yeah um that's definitely an idea
and and this sort of thing like it can
happen in different types of positions
not just this exact position
so if you just remember the pattern your
pawn here
knight here bishop here and and this
structure
just try and uh try and just internalize
this pattern of taking a knight before
because if you get something like this
you're pretty much guaranteed to get rid
of the bishop
um yeah now if we look at maybe a
slightly better way i can deal with this
let's say white just castles here
then you don't waste any time just take
the bishop
as you're playing all along queen will
take back
and then you get what we can call a very
nice french structure where you removed
white lights for bishop you have the c
file to work with
very often your rook can come to c8
either now you can complete the kingside
development first
it is still a question how you develop
your kingside pieces
um i'll throw in one move well
let's say you throw in rook ca because
it's a move you you play
i usually at some point yeah yeah
uh let's say i want to test you
tactically
you know yeah
[Laughter]
wait well there's always that chance
that there's always the chance of the
mouse slip and they don't move
oh yeah they they don't see how the the
board's connected most people should see
this
they're gonna move the queen yet uh but
there is a chance they'll move the queen
to uh
the wrong square where you you
completely exploit them
let's say they play queenie two this is
why it's really important to like
constantly look for tactics before you
kind of look for the natural moves
um oh yeah now i can go uh
i can go there and it'll take and i can
go there
i get there oh no you just lost all your
pieces
oh okay forget it forget it forget it
that was almost brilliant
uh i i was actually curious what your
follow-up was was going to be
you almost
it's good though it and it's it's very
important when you when you consider an
option like this you
visualize what's coming
whatever this is called now i'm going to
win a rook
or i'm going to win the exchange yep
bishop maybe bishop b5
yeah yeah uh we call this a skewer
okay sometimes like if the rook and
queen were
flipped it would be a pin where you'd
pin the rook to the queen but yeah
when the stronger piece is in front it's
a skewer a queen has to move somewhere
and then you win the rook for the bishop
so you win basically two points of
material
um so
and this like going back to just kind of
the general french ideas
when you remove white's light squared
bishop
uh and in that case for your knight and
you keep your own lights for a bishop
your light square bishop can be
sometimes twice as powerful because you
you're going to be controlling light
squares and white doesn't have the
bishop to really
contest the light squares well usually
the light square bishop of the french is
like a terrible
piece too right usually yeah it has this
reputation of being like the the biggest
problem with the french
because it's a bishop that's stuck
behind your pawn chain
but when you when you play the french
more and more you'll realize that your
bishop
sometimes it'll start off by just
hibernating
early in the game and then later in the
game it'll have opportunities to really
come alive
and very often it comes alive along this
diagonal
um and there's other cases sometimes
where you you bring the bishop to b5 to
eventually trade
like if white still have a bishop on d3
sometimes you go for the bishop trade
but
in this case you use it to win
that's material the kind of like going
c3 is exactly the
kind of move that is awesome for guys my
ranking right because
you're not giving up much and you're
giving them a chance to blunder
exactly i mean and a lot of players
i think would go to e2 like it's such a
natural move like the queen's attack you
don't want to move to d2 because it
blocks your bishop
so um i will say like the best move here
is knight c3 to develop the knight and
protect the queen this does walk into a
pin so maybe it's a bit less natural
um yeah and if he did that then you know
i would go like that um
yep completely fine yeah you you
pressure the pin piece you get ready to
develop your knight
and uh there's not too much to worry
about here for you
like there's not not a huge kingside
attack for whites
and you're still going to have the ideas
of pressuring this d4 pawn
with your not only with your queen but
with your knights
yeah so there's a lot of pressure points
here between the d4 pawn the knight on
c3
and you can kind of pick and choose
depending how light proceeds
of what what targets you want to focus
on
but i think this was kind of a good
initial example to show
just some some very typical ideas and
show how it can just be really
comfortable for you early on
um where you you strive to get rid of
this bishop early and then
then go ahead and kind of complete
development
yeah i love i i love getting
getting rid of that white square
bishop's plan so i've never heard that
one before that's that's good
okay yeah that's good and sometimes it's
not the most intuitive thing like maybe
the the niche gary course it'll cover
like the most theoretical lines first
where
white's playing like a super gm but a
lot of lower level players will
in one way or another uh not
hold on to their bishop in these
structures or end up losing the center
pawn
so it's good to know how to kind of
punish the the common mistakes from
light
now i don't want to overwhelm you with
like too many different
types of plans or ideas but i think this
is this is a good starting point
um and what i probably need to take
yeah can i so i take
oh whose move is it
i'm not entirely sure if we're synced up
um
oh let's let me actually clear the
board give me one moment here
all right oh maybe we are synced up
you see the pieces moving right yeah
okay
was there a moment you were you wanted
to ask about that i got to move the
bishop
i i almost made the same mistake again
that got my
queen uh yeah bishop d7 very important
yeah how to do d7 okay yeah there's a
few small details early on but
um what i was gonna recommend
is i think you should just start playing
this playing the french
when you encounter e4 in your online
games
okay and then then kind of reflect on
what you're running into most often
and then then we can build from there
like there's a lot of a lot of things we
can expand upon
and um i didn't do this initially but i
should kind of give you a breakdown
when you play the french there's a lot
of different things white can play as
well
we covered one of the most common lines
another thing you kind of have to be
ready for is exchange which is
also probably one of the most common
things you'll run into
at your level this one doesn't yeah this
one doesn't bother me
bother me is like okay you know
i can now i just come that way right or
i go uh
in the night out and castle king side
and
so and this should not bother you at all
because you you already have you have a
position where your pieces are not
restricted
and there's actually a lot of different
setups you can employ here
um and you can you can actually employ
something that resembles a joe bava
london
which i would be very much inclined to
show you
because even though this is a completely
different opening than job of london
you can basically do a setup where your
knight goes here
your bishop develops here here your
other bishop comes here your knight
comes here
you actually end up casting queen side
and then once you get a later attack on
the king side
um yeah uh i'll i'll i'll i'll be uh
more in tuned with that one i think
definitely and what i'm showing you is
actually a pretty
reputable setup against most things
white can
white can do and you you can you can go
from like a very kind of seemingly dry
symmetrical position to a really
exciting position if you get the
opposite side casting scenario
so it's a reverse uh reverse think
reverse trivada
pretty much maybe with a few minor
changes like sometimes your
your light squared bishop will come here
uh potentially to pin the knight
um there's cases where you you can still
choose
and uh but apart from that your the
pieces
actually go in in pretty much the same
squares as jobava london
so this should already be in your
wheelhouse
uh and maybe we can just play it out
from here and see how you uh
how you execute the setup
okay so i'm going to give you a few
small pointers as we go ahead
i'm going to say that you you don't
start with bishop f5
because you're not sure yet if your
bishop wants to go here here
you should start by developing your
queenside knights
oh the queenside knight okay you know
your knight's going to go here in the
setup
yeah for sure okay and the whole plan is
to eventually castle queenside
okay so this is just what we call being
flexible
you play the move that you know you're
going to play first to keep some other
options open
okay um let's say white plays bishop d3
um
awesome there very flexible move this
this is like the best square for your
darts for bishop
in these sort of positions and um
again you're staying flexible with your
other pieces
i'll save my castles
okay
well i could pin your knight
now to your queen and that gets the
bishop out of the way
so that i can castle queenside that
looks like a reasonable plan
love it yeah when you play bishop here
you're you're pinning the knight you
might have the idea of taking
um of course you always have to be aware
of the potential complications but
uh you are probably threatening to win
the pawn here so white does have to be
careful
uh let's imagine white throws in the
check
a lot of problem go there and develop
yeah just developing blocking the check
and you've you've already developed all
your minor pieces so you're
arguably ahead in development here and
you still do need to castle
you're still threatening the pawn uh
very natural for like to play c3
okay uh i don't want to remove any of
the tension there
and i want to get castled i'm going to
move my clean up
and protect my bishop love it uh
and get ready we'll play this move
awesome and this is really the the ideal
setup
um and then going forward from here i
think the
like understanding the attacking plans
and ideas are also
pretty now i'm going all in i'm running
my pawns down the h file
g-file and yeah what happens so
the the pawn storm is so natural here
like especially moving the h pawn all
the way up
like if you get your pawn to h3 there it
can create a lot of weaknesses in
white's camp
if white ever plays h3 there is a
potential of sacrificing
on top of that you have like f6 g5 is
typical
sometimes you bring your knight in to g6
and then f4
so you just have a lot of kind of
attacking moves in your toolbox and you
can choose them
kind of as you wish um
i imagine if you start playing the
french more and more you'll kind of
you'll
you'll get these positions and you'll
kind of get a better sense of
of what happens further down the road
i just want to want you to play one more
move and then uh
yeah h5 very fine um
and yeah concept of of h4 h3 coming and
i think this is yeah this kind of goes
back to your job
london attacking wheelhouse so yeah
um so that might be another reason why
the french is a good fit for you because
if you get the exchange variation that's
already in
in the sort of position you you know how
to deal with
yeah no i i love that
i love that concept because it it
remember
it minimizes number of things i got to
think about
right um definitely okay they do
exchange i know try to get to
i'm trying to get the reverse or trying
to get jaba's black
they don't do exchange i got to bring
the queen out i got to make sure i
get the d7 bishop in there
yeah yeah if you can kind of distinguish
the different types of positions you're
getting
um and kind of categorize them and and
know the different ideas for each one
that will
hopefully simplify things for you
because i know i guess when you learn
the french
you're learning like a few different
setups but there's still hopefully
things you can you can fully understand
and play at a good level
um i don't want to overwhelm you with
too much like more new information i
think
the fact that we covered the exchange
and the like the exchange and the
advance are the two most common things
you'll run into
uh we might want to save the other other
options white can play for next time
um you're not gonna make me uh i am and
one and one last one
what was that you're not going to turn
me into an eye on
one lesson i i wish i had those
abilities it takes
it takes a little bit of patience and
um i mean based on what you've said
at least in our previous conversation it
seems like you're studying
way more than a lot of master level
players these days
i i don't know any master level player
who's been studying as much as you
so you're you're probably catching up up
to us in some regard like you're
improving at a faster rate
yeah i'm also 50 and you don't learn
nearly as fast
um when you're old so enjoy it while
you're young
but you're you're still you're still
showing that you can
you can improve like you're not it's not
that you're 50 and you're just not going
to improve at all like
the fact that you've only been playing
chess for a year and you're already at
like a pretty good level
i think it's giving some hope to the the
older older chess players out there
you're being very kind um and and thank
you for your time
morning i know we've got you know big
tournaments on and lots of other stuff
you've been doing but um thanks to the
audience as well
yeah yeah it's been a pleasure uh eric's
channel
i will beg you to do so um
i really appreciate the future really
great content i've been a big fan for
the last year since i discovered
jess um that's great mostly through
streams um i look forward to our next
lesson together thank you
yeah and i guess the homework i would
give you
is to play
at least a handful of french games
doesn't matter if you get crushed early
yeah if by a handful you mean 50 uh
game on yeah i think uh that probably
won't be a problem for you
but uh but but play with play them with
a growth mindset like you're
you're gonna run into things you
probably have never seen before
and uh make note of any games that you
you want to potentially go over or
like games where you weren't sure what
to do or weren't sure where you went
wrong because
those will be the the most valuable to
learn from
for sure okay well i've got some new
ideas to try thank you so much awesome
yeah it's been a pleasure we'll be in
touch all right
i'll talk soon okay bye